good morning everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 28 object class
safe special containment procedures no
special means are needed to contain at
this time SCP 28 has not shown any
change in size position or shape during
the entire period of its containment but
access must be restricted currently SCP
28 is contained on site cipher as SCP 28
is not transportable by any known means
SCP 28 is sealed in a 6 by 6 by 3 meter
concrete room with a single door with
two armed personnel stationed outside
only authorized personnel are to be
allowed exposure to SCP 28 and extreme
care must be taken at all times while
SCP 28 is itself harmless the effect can
be very damaging to the unprepared see
document al 28 11:25 description SCP 28
is located in an abandoned storage yard
outside a copper mine in northern
Michigan SCP 28 has no detectable
physical presence of any kind but its
effect occurs in a 2.1 meter cube around
what is commonly held as the center of
SCP 28 all forms of scanning and testing
in the area of a CP 28 have shown no
abnormal readings adding or removing
objects or attempting to remove dirt
from under SCP 28 has no effect in
altering the size or shape of a CP 28
area-of-effect
nor the onset or quality of the effect
subjects entering a CP 28 are within
three to six seconds struck by total and
complete knowledge of a subject this
knowledge thus far is completely random
in both signs and usefulness and
sometimes goes unnoticed for extended
periods of time
more profound knowledge generally has a
stronger effect with some cases this
effect can be experienced multiple times
by exiting and re-entering SCP 28 but
can result in increasingly strong
migraines and dizziness after two
exposures SCP 28 came to the
foundation's attention after research
into news reports of a local miner who
submitted a design for a cold fusion
reactor to the US Patent Office mister
reported that it just came to me like a
bolt out of the blue news and subjects
were suppressed and contained after the
discovery on the CP 28 and the reactor
designs implemented in the containment
of SCP 1995 subsequent testing of SCP 28
has yielded mixed results document al 28
1114 partial information retrieval log
for January 5th note all knowledge is
perfect total and eidetic every phone
book entry for New York City in 1998 how
to redesign the internal combustion
engine to run on human blood using only
pre-existing parts note full redesign
takes four hours and runs at higher
efficiency than gasoline location of
keys for a Buick LeSabre the proper
method of care for a mole rat colony
origin and history of 12 SCP objects
note the main family history of the
blackthorn family located in london
england geological structure of the
earth beneath greenland including
several unknown caves document il-28
1125 log e 11 to subject d 1182 exposed
to SCP 28 subject began to cry and went
into fetal position showing signs of
high distress unresponsive to
questioning outside stimulus for several
days
lapsed into catatonia shortly after
stating that this is not life the
subject passed into a coma and died
shortly thereafter cause of death was
attributed to shock a 12-7 agent
accidentally exposed to SCP 28 agents
showed signs of sudden surprise and
bemusement when question agent requested
a moment to gather my thoughts plates
after a few seconds agent laughed shook
his head and removed his service pistol
from its holster agent then shot and
wounded doctor and killed agent and
before being restrained post-incident
interrogation revealed agent had
extensive knowledge of classified
foundation activities and several SCP
objects he had not previously been
exposed to including SCP 26 69 any
foundation personnel found to have
entered a CP 28 area of effect are to be
detained indefinitely document al 28 11
28 log experiment 189 subject D 98 43
was exposed to SCP 28 19th of March 11
46 examination of subject revealed
abnormal respiratory actions
19th of March 1337 questioning revealed
subject had learned to recycle the
carbon dioxide inside his body 19th of
March 1721 repeated attempts to teach
the skill to other d-class personnel
failed 24th of March
1211 subject terminated July 18th 1503
autopsy reveals no abnormal organ
formations July 18th 1837 researchers
notes doctor seriously how the hell did
he do that well something tells me that
the Ethics Committee is hiding something
what do you think that's one thing you
learn working here pretty much
everything here is a lie and if you find
it out to be true there's probably
little bits of lies sprinkled in there
except me though I don't lie I don't
ever lie anyway that about does it for
today thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you are all
dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Muslim Mookie slump god Justin day
John Porter captain Gorge fluffy dread
my archive curator neck tie verbal
cootie tench cheese whip depths McGee
and oblong dish boy if you would like a
special Thank You the end of each of my
videos and some other cool stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
volume thank you
you
[Music]